boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still on-site at triple-a the
American Anthropological Association we
are now sitting down with dr. Maria visi
Renu hi hi how are you thank you for
coming out to the show I'm excited to be
here yes I'm super happy to have you
this is gonna be a lot of fun we're
gonna talk about a lot of very
interesting things and something let me
give a quick background quick background
on Maria is she's a research associate
in lecture at Loyola Marymount
University in Los Angeles she's a
researcher at the Center for the Study
of Los Angeles it's a global health ph.d
at Arizona State University where she
was understanding how people build
mental models of complex health
phenomena and she created the eating
perception lab and now also an
evangelist of science communication
journal Club providing scientific
community with evidence-based tips on
how to engage the public and as you know
we care a lot about science
communication on the show so we're
really excited to unpack this first of
all first of all how the heck did you
get involved in anthropology it's a
really strange story I'm from Ukraine I
studied business in my bachelor's
because that was the way to get out of
the country and live somewhere else then
I got into health personally and I
thought at some point there was a lady I
was managing a health food store
something like a local Whole Foods a
lady came in asked me for advice I gave
her advice she said yeah but what's your
degree and I said none so I thought okay
I'm kind of going back to school
did my MS in health promotion which is
like Public Health I kind of liked it
but I was mostly interested in how
people get to understand what it means
to you well and that's a little bit more
anthropology than public health
interventions so I ended up in Arizona
with the global health degree it was
completely new there was only one person
graduating and there was so much freedom
to do whatever you wanted to do it's
very interdisciplinary so it's not just
anthropology it's not just Public Health
my research was really a bunch of
psychology nutrition and medical
anthropology combined into a weird thing
nobody else
doing so I did that and so I was
studying how people the way you said it
is correct but I make it sound very
complicated if I had to simplify it it's
gonna be I study why people believe
certain things are healthy to eat and
why they think there's a certain way to
eat foods so yeah so that's that because
the way that we seed the world and what
though if we only have one perception on
something on a complex issue that's
going to immediately impact the way that
we see things versus if we have ten or
twenty or however many perspectives
we're trying to synthesize into one that
could lead us to having a greater
knowledge about what we're eating or how
we're behaving with our health did you
know that you when we wait how old were
you were you born in Ukraine yeah and
then Jim so like 18 you moved to the I
was actually fifteen when I won the
giant competition that was paid by the
US government
whoa to send kids from those areas for
know English well has some potential it
was called future leaders exchange
program it was called flax so I was an
exchange student in high school I met an
American host family that it was in in
Indiana I was there for a year went back
home started my business degree then
eventually came back to Indiana and
finished it there so that's when I
stayed alone my whole family is home so
my brother is now in Los Angeles with me
but it's very recent yes
other than that everyone's there so I
was weirdly alone here for about 12
years yeah just making my way through
yeah but now how did how did you know
that you wanted to come to the United
States I I loved English I loved
studying different cultures I was really
into sci-fi videogames and a lot of them
are set in America which was so all the
terrible horror stuff Resident Evil
Cellular oh cool that's my thing so
actually the reason I know the language
is so much better than all my peers at
that time is because I started playing
video games all of them were not quite
you know you know sold certain ways not
translated so you had to learn the
English get a dictionary out
actually understand what's happening
interesting that's I love it most people
wouldn't know think about video games
being able to teach a language that it's
like more tunes in some other countries
me it was a video game yes yes story
heavy so I had to learn the words you
know now I envision you slaying zombies
in Resident Evil you know I'm really
excited for the remake that's coming out
soon yeah like six is that what it is oh
no they were making the second one which
is the originating the second one do
they stop at five or what was six
something attention but okay yeah
shooting I just wound the story the
stories or stories are very interesting
video source so okay so this is cool so
you come out to you know to Indiana it
now what is it like I just want to know
about this this is an interesting point
along the story is what is it like when
you are dealing with like an American
host family you know uh I was you know I
have to tell you whoever psychologists
picked me were right because you have to
be very flexible that's why the program
is called flex I think I don't that so
well that they wanted to see me back in
a couple of years and let me stay there
for free while I was finishing my
college was really amazing family in
Indiana it's there's always differences
right
Machado uh its Deanna Hershey she's not
with us anymore but her daughter Deb
Hershey I saw her had wait a couple
years ago she live still in Indiana I
love her so yeah shout out to them but
they made it possible for me to be here
because otherwise what would I do
you know it's expensive to be in this
country especially alone so yeah yeah
that's that's huge Wow and so you have
the flood the flexibility cuz I've also
we just we just had a show where we were
talking to someone that's homeless about
about street life and and when we were
talking to them they had went through 48
foster care centers and again it was
because of a lot of inflexibility when
you get to a foster family that you keep
just butt heads and so when you are more
flexible with things and there's a lot
of other variables that go into it but
yeah it's it's just being open
culturally which is probably why I ended
up in anthropology all along because
when I first came into United States a
funny thing is that some of the things I
noticed at first
and it'd have been really big theories
in my dissertation work I never realized
that until recently when I first came to
United States and I was in high school
and somebody gave a bunch of pencils to
everyone to for everyone to get a pencil
right Americans would take a pencil and
pass it along some it takes Beth and I
was like whoa
something's weird here if you were in
Ukraine and that happens I'm the first
person in line I'm gonna start handing
out every single pencil out and if I'm
done and I don't have one myself I'm
like I guess I have to go get one for
myself there there's a very known
dimensional psychology of collectivism
versus individualism
yes so finally you know Eastern Europe
is considered more collectivist than
Americans were more individualistic and
therefore me was the perfect first
example I had no idea yeah that was 15
but funnily in my dissertation work
that's one of the theories I had for why
people think about food differently okay
we have to talk about that that's so
cool that's that's I think that's the
that's a very very relatable story the
pencil story it's yeah yeah there's a
huge difference the first person that
gets the bundle either passes them a
bundle long or they go and give
everything the group first you know even
if you suffer yeah yeah yeah and and
then this is also another example of
this actually is when you walk into a
restaurant with a group of people and
you're it's one of those self-serve
places maybe but Chipotle or whatever
huh and you're the group orders food and
since out you're you're the one that
gets four water glasses four knives four
Forks ten napkins and you bring it all
to the table mm-hmm so yeah
interesting interesting yeah there's
that that's so cool okay so and that's
good that you now now tell us about the
transition from Indiana to Arizona yeah
it was actually very tough because here
I was coming I'm always the new kid it
sucks first time in a business and
marketing then I come to public health
arena and I don't know okay I'm starting
to catch up it's been two years when I
come to her is on a state and I realize
oh this is all the less health way more
anthropology
and I get thrown into a completely
different field that I ended up
absolutely loving because hey they're
able to answer any question you can
think about about humans and related to
us there can be like cool let's figure
out how we're gonna test that and what
theories we're gonna apply and the
methodology and doing we can answer
whatever you have asked it's amazing
right it's fun so when I ended up there
the hardest part about a PhD probably to
figure out what you're gonna do
sometimes you have an idea sometimes
your professor my join you on there you
know project I come in with all these
crazy ideas and all this nutrition stuff
that nobody was necessarily doing so I
had I had a really great mentor that dr.
Daniel Houska is a superstar and he's
here at some point during the conference
and he helped me pick my topic and it
was a weird one it was my first time
here I knew I was coming to the
conference and there was a call for
papers about blame
so how people blame different foods on
chronic diseases across cultures that's
why I went back to Ukraine I was like
let's see how Eastern Europeans feel
about things and I found an interesting
cool thing that okay if I said no yes so
I was looking at health perceptions
perceptions of healthy eating and I
started noticing I couldn't quite test
it yet that Eastern Europeans generally
everyone generally when you ask them
what's healthy eating they start talking
about foods what makes them bad good
healthy and healthy then they might
mention some other things like maybe you
shouldn't overeat late in the day maybe
you should always have breakfast
maybe you shouldn't skip meals those
kind of other things I have to do the
way you consume whatever it is
regardless of what it is
and I noticed that Eastern Europeans
cared seem to care more about those the
ways that you eat food I call them
eating styles styles that's what I
decided to call it yes I knew that's a
good way to put it yeah yeah and I was
like oh that's interesting that's I
wonder if that's true so I started
paying attention and the literature on
collectivism they will you know once you
go into this in psychology there are
known cognitive differences between
collectivists and individualists
societies collectivistic societies tend
to have more what they call a holistic
pattern of
tenshun whereas they think of something
they'll remember more about the context
than the focal feature and
individualistic site is tend to have a
more analytical type of attention where
they'll remember more about like a
certain thing they do you know how there
is a picture of aquarium with some fish
and some background some whatever it is
greenery I collect a collectivistic
person who's like scores really higher
in a collectivist scale you let them
look at it take it away say what do you
remember they'll remember a lot more
detail about what what everything else
looked like then this central fish so
anyway so that's kind of cool right and
I thought could that be applied to food
perceptions because I'm looking first at
the foods people think are good and bad
to eat and then I'm looking about all
this like kind of context of when do you
eat it yes um at what times at what
intervals so not focusing on the food I
thought wouldn't it be crazy if partly
why Eastern Europeans care more about
all this context of eat eating Styles is
there a cognition style yeah and
actually tested it in two studies yeah
it was partly responsible so it wasn't
about the fact that all these people
live in Ukraine and Romania Eastern
Europe and for some reasons they care
more about eating Styles it was actually
explained by their level of collectivism
so their cognition made them think a
little bit differently about healthy
eating and focused more about all these
different aspects of the way you consume
different foods and that's really cool
because there's always been a lot of
focus on nutrition nutrients the foods
that you eat obviously but now there's
so much literature amazing literature
coming out about the intermittent
fasting and stuff like that on the
importance of the timing of when you eat
how many times a day what's the time
range it really matters and it seems to
be related and to all sorts of chronic
conditions anabolic syndrome so the way
we consume food really matters too so I
was really excited about it it's just
like a constant stream of glucose for
the cells versus a period of time
without any glucose having to burn fat
then sure you eat and then the Yankees
yeah has a lot to do with our internal
clocks they're KDM rhythms actually I
mentioned to you earlier that I do like
this little whiteboard videos where I
yeah yeah yeah that was good yeah and my
favorite ones the one I did on my
dissertation topic and it was about the
time of eating and explaining why that
would matter and there is great
literature on this now showing that
there's certain clocks in your body the
way your organs and everything works
works off light patterns like is light
is it at night what time of the day it
is but it can also be kind of messed up
if you eat it funny times like if you
late at night
it's sort of deregulates certain things
and eventually it might be a risk factor
for certain diseases so that's kind of
crazy and I think that's cool cuz a lot
of us we eat like late at night right
totally oh yeah I'm such a culprit no
now you're trying to think of all the
things are doing wrong well I love how
you made a distinction between what we
eat and the eating styles because I
don't think there is enough of a of a
conversation about eating styles I think
we've had a couple on the show where we
just talked about how interesting it is
that we've never eaten three times a day
with so many options with 100% fold
stomach every time we eat and so this is
a new phenomenon in civilization and so
when you look back throughout evolution
it was it wasn't a it wasn't an 8 a.m.
noon and 6:00 p.m. full meal every time
type of thing so and there was
definitely not
the refined sugar water that we that we
that we drink now sodas and all that
other kind of stuff so high fructose
corn syrup so so there I like I like how
the you know eating perception comes
with styles that's that was so cool
teach us more about this because the
idea of collectivist thinking driving
more I guess determining a little bit
more nuance around meaning versus
individualistic thinking that was a
pretty interesting one I thought it was
crazy at first I said no way let's do
cool you know but yep it was there so it
predicts you're more likely to pay
attention to all this context stuff
about eating but it's not obviously the
only thing you know for example back
home you know I was born in USSR
it was all USSR back then and even then
some of these eating styles are actually
more like ancient wisdoms from coming
from generation past that care about
stuff like that like hey you don't eat
late in the day or at certain hour or
you shouldn't be snacking between when
you eat a lot of this stuff wants to
start looking there's very little
research on it but some of it is from
Eastern Europe someone's coming from
Asia there's a lot of very interesting
ideas about timing of food from there so
it's not really new but you know why
it's not really on our radar because
it's so hard to study people's diets
sometimes it's a lot easier to figure
out what they ate then all the other
factors like when a movie they do what
they distracted there's all this
literature on watch interior talking to
friends you tend to be eat a bit more
without being more full you know so
there's all these things and you might
we might not be paying attention to and
they met her as well just a little plug
I've never met this person but there's a
panda left because the professor is
called dr. panda in California and he's
studying all of these contextual factors
about eating there is a free app you do
and you like have to say what you're
doing while you're eating and what time
it is and he's sort of looking at yes
like a map of when every intake happens
so I'm really excited to see like what
that come up
comes out - yes outcomes I think like
weight management showing that you lose
weight much easier if you eat within a
certain window so like a lot of this
more like fads about eating to have some
really good Tristan yes you know yeah
you mean it's eating from noon until
8:00 is that's already not eating for 16
hours a day so and you can easily do two
meals at each time at the end caps whoa
and then that's cool that it's tough to
do quantify itself on your own eating
habits because it's a lot of information
to log and we're already very it's you
see in many ways I mean some of this are
and you know I one of my favorite topics
is evolution of human food preferences
even though I wasn't I'm not an
evolutionary you know person but while I
was at Arizona State there is a it's
called evolutionary medicine center and
it's Center for evolutionary medicine
that looks at how we can look at our
health and disease from more
evolutionary perspective to really get
at the ultimate causes of why we are the
way we are anyway I took a course with
dr. Nessie who is running the center I
really learned a lot and then I ended up
writing a couple of articles for
encyclopedia of Aleutian psychology on
how people perceive food how they make
their choices so I love that stuff and
yes the environment we live in these
days is extremely different and it's the
most natural thing that we're all
overweight you know why wouldn't we be
we're sitting around doing nothing
there's a lot of great talks this
weekend about that as well evolutionary
anthropologists yeah they're looking
into that as well yeah yeah the yeah
this is yes we've heard sitting as the
new cancer we've heard so many things
how you sit together which I went to
that which which is like it's more like
you know on the floors you're not
leaning anything you're sitting on the
floor so you're kind of engaging more
muscle yeah very good sort of or you're
like sitting really low I can't show it
right now I'm wearing a dress yes yes
but you know sitting on a chair is
- relaxing you're not quite right yeah
you know see if you said in a different
way let's imagine there's nothing to sit
on there on the ground you actually
would be engaging more muscle you'd be
better off it was so cool and you're
also moving around more because you get
sore you might lean on an elbow you
might let Ling a leg out those micro
movement support like really matter huge
we had a bit of conversation from from
Stanford who's working on like furniture
that does things like makes you like
move from side to side while you're work
yeah and like other interesting things
like the chair will actually run away
from you and hide because it will be on
its own like that's pretty cool and then
it'll make you go and like get the chair
and stuff and yeah it's just yeah yeah I
know it's interesting stuff like that
that's amazing and there's evidence Greg
just went to a poster session where
there's an amazing guy for 40 years
studying diabetes and his show and it's
all about the equally the contained body
the way that everything is engineered to
just not move much much and it's like we
need to exercise much we just need to be
moving doing normal yes yes so yes he's
on to something very interesting
manipulations of our environments to
make us move more and that's really fun
because it also gets blood flowing it
your cognition increasing if you feel
looser it's not as tight you live longer
there's so many important points to it
yeah so okay now what now what else
about eating styles cuz I'm still I'm so
fascinated with the distinction that you
made between eating styles and the food
we eat and they just they're being such
a big distinction so interesting what
else you know it's funny thing is that
took me a lot of work to make that
distinction because when I first
suggested it's saying hey doesn't it
make sense this all of this the way I
did it I had people read a bunch of
cards with statements about healthy
eating on them and I knew some of them
would be focused on food and some would
be focused on in the way that you
consume it when I try to publish it I
got feedback saying
things that are different obviously are
but I had to go through all of the
statistics and the models to show like
no no everyone perceives them as two
different groups they're kind of part of
the same thing they're all about eating
but there's something to be said about
and I think Michael Pollan called that
nutrition isn't like this real big focus
on what's in the foods in terms of the
nutrients and not thinking about other
characteristics of food like hey maybe
how they're produced right yes but it's
important to go even a little bit
further from that and how do you consume
them exactly and so it's not just how
later early it's not just the pattern
meaning like is it better to have a
couple of big meals is it okay to snack
more often but it's also things like
what are you doing while you're eating
yes traction wise that's right it's also
the state you're eating in I didn't
really go into that into my research but
I eaten in a positive atmosphere I used
to rest so there's and there could be
more of these eating styles that aspects
that really matter I was really I was
looking at what people were telling me
in the interviews so I focused a lot on
that and my Eastern Europeans really
cared about not eating late at night
yeah and though I don't do any kind of
clinical work that's when I started
doing all this research like wait is
there evidence for this that's like yes
all this research is coming out about
eating after a certain hour eaten close
to bedtime yeah it affects our
metabolism in not the best ways yeah so
there's that could be more I have to do
more yes yes I want Wow okay you you
gave this really interesting sort of
like I don't know I don't know I don't
know exactly know how to go centric
circles I don't think have it make sense
but there's there's there's a different
way to visualize it but it's a way to
visualize where you have the
nutritionist sort of thinking of what
are the nutrients in the food and then
like the next layer would be like or a
layer abstracted from the nutrition
would it be how is that food sourced and
produced yes
whole is the process you know you're
going a little bit further right yes so
they're important and then the next
layer is how are you consuming
that food is what style are you
consuming it with and you you gave a
very interesting example about the
whether you're happy or sad while you're
eating food there's another there's
another one of I I personally found that
find that when I am mmm when I give like
gratitude to the food that I find more I
guess connection to earth and connection
and nutrients and yeah not so I'm like
blessing the meal and blessing earth
forgive evils pray before they there's
something to it probably something the
food and then also the when I'm there's
I'm starting to really feel a difference
between when I'm eating and I'm just
eating slowly and looking at the food
versus when I'm watching a video while
I'm there's definitely some evidence for
that the fact that that matters the pace
is another thing I forgot it definitely
matters as well and so slowly yeah I
enjoy eating so that's good that's
really good actually on like chewing
your food like whatever grandma used to
say true your food or you said grandma I
was just about to tell you at some point
somebody told me what is all this stuff
in the car it's like grandma science
science it's coming it is true that it's
been around and whatever like when I
think about that you growing up and
Ukraine things that your parents would
say there's like all these little things
like oh when you're aging you're not
supposed to be chatting or talking just
like focus good time don't hurry you
know so there's a lot to it and now
there's finally more evidence because
people are focusing on that and not just
a nutritional composition which is also
important but we know a lot about it we
know it matters you know there's more to
the picture yeah so yeah whoa grandma
being cutting-edge science that's I like
that it's so so interesting it's kind of
like The Linde effect where the
knowledge that's been preserved over
time will likely be around that much
longer but all this new stuff that comes
out every single day yeah it could be
obsolete tomorrow because it's new stuff
it's brand-new
so that's that's so interesting yeah and
there's something quite I don't know
nautical western about nutritionism
because that's where the science is
coming from so the only other literature
I found that was looking into eating the
styles or whatever they choose to call
it was like Japan Turkey yeah and so I
couldn't quite find anything else and
that's going back to this older beliefs
about what it means to eat well Japan
has a Hara Hachi Bou you eat till you're
three-quarters full
that's another it's definitely some cut
you know eating style consideration what
was turkeys the its it wasn't anything
particularly cold it was just showing
that they were interviewing a bunch of
workers in the factory or whatnot and
they were showing like hey all this
people really cared about the time and
the fact that there are certain meals so
they cared about a lot and not as much
about nutrition as some of the other
societies and I was like oh there it is
again so it's so I think it's coming
back through science now through
evidence and people are gonna start
paying attention Wow so there might be a
lot more weight on how we eat than what
we eat if we're eating the okay like
okay sized portions not excessive
portions and if we're eating maybe to
medium ish meals a day and then we're
intermittently fasting it might not even
matter potentially so much if we are
eating like all the people are now free
vegan and paleo and carnivorous only and
stuff so so because I've also heard
people just say that oh if you're paleo
you can just eat all you want all day
long like no problem or if you're
fruitarian you can just eat only fruits
as many fruits as you want all day long
I I love these topics I love white
people going to alternative health
that's because I did before I've tried
stuff like that so I tried it all yeah I
kind of liked it oh well there's my
favorite but for no particular reason I
just did a guest lecturer at Loyola
Marymount University you know
at Chicago and in evolutionary
psychology class and I think they were
all really impressed because like you
say hey you can eat anything as long as
it's paleo
I had this amazing slide I wish I had it
here of trying to get people to send it
to me and all I'm really proud of it and
it's like all this fruits and vegetables
right there our paleo that are great to
eat and then I show what they would look
like ten thousand years ago and it just
looks all like grass and fiber and
disgusting stuff that you would never
want to eat people at ASU there was one
researcher studying hunter-gatherers
somewhere in the Amazon and one of the
things I remembered from his talk he
said they hate vegetables they're
disgusting they're bitter they're
fibrous they want food all the time so
it's not just us that don't like
vegetables it's all the hand together
because this vegetables look like weeds
you know they've been domesticated so
technically you can't eat paleo now even
if you really wanted to it's just no way
and Apple didn't look the same way a
banana horn used to be like this that
for should see everybody knows corn but
everything else you can imagine
right now it's just that's not how it
looked so I love it illusionary stuff
yeah
incident so there a lot of the
hunter-gatherer was was fruit or meat it
was less so the vegetable well first of
all it was whatever was available that
wasn't available that'd be doing a lot
of root vegetables and figure out how to
consume it cooking was important because
you could make something that's just not
at about all into something more or less
okay yeah yeah and then I went to
another it was last year here at
triple-a it was the best talk ever that
made me realize that all of this protein
in let's call him Paleolithic diets
there was a lot of variation but a lot
of it could have been completely insects
so we're not talking about totally yeah
and the race is coming did you see
crooked bars yeah we have there's a
whole resurgence we had chips on our
show we there's a whole resurgence of
you on that the West Western people are
looking at the East going like the
crickets and then we're like how can we
package crickets to make people eat
crickets I tried those bars yeah yeah DT
she can't taste normal too
yeah it's the way to go problem
interesting okay what about what about
now with what's going on with you with
the research I really am interested in
this at the Center for the Study of Los
Angeles okay what the hell are you
researching about Los Angeles it was
it's very new to me because even though
the center is not in any particular
field they're closest to political
science so a lot of the stuff we do is
public opinion work right now we had a
big election study it's really cool
because I'm trying to find ways to ask
very interesting question from a lot of
people from a like a representative
sample so when we do our big survey
every January who actually can tell how
Angelina it's things like everybody in
LA County because we do amazing
methodology at getting people that will
represent the whole place you know the
whole area I want to insert some health
things as well with ten but I've been
there for less than a year and so the
kind of work that we do looks at more
about how people feel about current
issues so a lot of the things that we do
ends up in the media or decision-makers
get a hold of that information saying
look at look at that people in Los
Angeles a relay against this and they
really like that and they use that
information so it's really cool and more
applied than I'm used to but I do want
to insert a little bit more health in
there that's a good one yeah that I
think that would be really useful data
no no give me a give me an idea at how
one conducts the research to be not not
biased to have the best sample size you
know the way we do it at study LA that's
the short version instead of saying the
whole study la la la yeah we actually so
to get 2,400 people to answer a survey
this 20 minutes long stuff we outsource
so somebody else does all the calling
it's mostly on the phone some of it is
online but you have to really combine in
because people gonna answer the phone at
different very conservative the
that you want to have a better
presentation so you have to get some
online people as well and once you get
all that data and it's really
complicated because we do chorus we want
all sorts of ethnicities and we want to
make sure we get everyone so if we
didn't get enough Filipinos will keep
callin until we get it enough of them so
it gets complicated it takes some time
once we get the data you can always wait
you can see what your data looks like
and you say but I want this to represent
the entire like count you let's say so
you go to US Census you see what the
demographics are and then you weigh your
data to match that better and then you
report results okay okay so then you
Susan let me see so then you take with
the census it says that X amount of
people let's say 10% of people are
Philip you know let's say that and then
you the data that you've collected only
3% of the data so V okay and then so
then you need to go and pull more
Filipinos to bring that the data Sara
you can adjust it statistically so you
only take a look at random sample size
down to make them ten person you can
manipulate it in certain very careful
ways and it's not just that it's age its
affinity it's it's several factors where
they live if we got way too many people
from the valley there's not that many
people that live there so we need to
kind of statistically diminish them a
little bit so we get the correct a final
picture and that's why it's amazing I've
never done representative samples so for
me with very new this year and it's
really impressive because then you can
say that all right here's how people
felt about sexual harassment or what not
and that's exactly how people in LA
County feel representative yeah now when
you're doing public opinion you actually
want to be able to say like that's how
people feel now just like here's how our
about how other people feel and then we
can say break it down be like this is
how people from this ethnic group feel
or that one or this age category that
gets really interesting we just had an
election study but a hundred twenty I
had a hundred twenty-five undergraduate
students trained in six hundred polling
place location in LA County collecting
data Oh
that's great what were they collecting
one was an exit poll where you do ask a
couple of questions like how did you
vote because that you actually get the
real numbers later you'll be able to see
how close your data is and we did really
well and LA Times just picked up some of
our data and then we asked a bunch of
questions about the perceptions of the
voting process if they had any issues we
really care about that because we can
take it back to LA County register a
quarter there are changing the election
process to voting centers and they want
to see how do people feel do people know
what's happening and do they perceive
any benefits of what they're doing so
they're using it for all kinds of ways
it's so cool it's it's all kinds of cool
stuff that doesn't have any to do with
health but I think it's so much so it's
a new thing for me but another big thing
I do is still am involved with health
part of the science communication
Journal Club yep the whole point is to
help experts scientists anywhere know
how to how would you talk to the public
how would you talk to a friend or
somebody on Facebook about this thing
the more you're in grad school the less
to remember about how to talk to people
I think you sort of lose it you get
really deep into a topic you get it so
well you know it's so well and then you
have you find it difficult to explain it
to someone else so people need to be
aware of it you know and just make sure
they have the right skills so we just
cover the latest research on how do you
communicate science in my area is for
the nutrition yes I do a lot of like
food technology thanks I wonder what
your perspective is on this because
we've now had probably a couple years
now so maybe the third year that were
really passionate about about science
communication we're starting to think
maybe there are certain people that need
to just go really really hard into just
the research and then maybe they need a
liaison to communicate the science so
someone that will hang out with them a
lot learn about it and then go and speak
to the public more professionally about
it because they just don't want to it's
not there's not interesting to them yeah
and so maybe that's true in some cases
but then there's also this amazing
amount of people which is probably the
majority of people that
are interested in speaking to the public
about what their research is but then
they're not able there's not
environments like kind of this like it's
almost like an open mic night for comedy
mmm and they do have stuff there's stuff
like that now there's like astronomy on
tap and there's science cafe science no
base laser talks another one of our
friends Bureau runs those so yeah
there's actually they're starting to
form
they're starting about that but it's not
that much yet no yeah and and so I'm I
wanted to hear your perspective on that
because you started talking about it
like the more that you focus on the
research the less you really go and
socialize which is kind of it's the how
I feel it's kind of I feel similarly
about that and and so we actually have
these conversations of scientists and
this is a very very introduced is a very
interesting point because more people
feel you're the way that we're talking
about it and but but also they feel on
them when the man the majority of them
actually want a place for them to be
able to teach but they just don't have
that place yeah it also builds a very
interesting muscle the muscle of public
speaking which is a completely different
look you have to synthesize your complex
and nuanced into relatable messages ya
know this is very very important and I
understand complete the people you know
there's a lot of pressure to publish and
to do research and to teach it's
overwhelming to be a faculty member so
trying to figure out how to go yeah
where are you gonna go let's say you're
doing social media how do you do social
media other people are really
overwhelmed by that and how do you do it
well instead of everyone suddenly
turning back when you're in and you know
it gets political or emotional or
whatnot so a lot of people just turned
off by it they're like it's a lot of
work I don't get I mean it's not part of
like what my university cares about
right now and I just don't know how to
do too well so with a science
communicational Journal Club one we do
is like if you're already kind of
interested but you're not sure where to
start okay you can join our
Chad listen to the podcast let's just
see what's going on what kind of tips we
can give you but yeah we don't provide
the space for it obviously and I mean I
was talking to a lot of people here just
reminding them you're younger you're
just still doing it you have some time
you need to start building those skills
now because it does get harder and you
do go deeper into your research and you
get really comfortable with academic
talk and writing and you have to write a
certain way for peer review and you just
forget how to say things simpler and
that's not good you're building a muscle
over timing I like that you gotta do it
you're gonna make yeah there's no
incentive sometimes you know it just
takes time and let's say universities
like walls already just publish you know
do you think yeah I guess is a big
incentive I think for us to potentially
communicate to other people about the
importance of it is that the more that
you work that muscle the better you get
at synthesizing the nuance into
relatable messages which will then
inspire other people the public to care
about it absolutely important everybody
recognizes it it's just lack of time and
it's difficult yes yeah people who could
be hanging out with scientists or
whatnot chatting with them and then
explain it to someone else that's
another great opportunity there are
people who do that on Twitter I see
sometimes they summarize somebody else's
writing to make it more simple and
accessible so that's kind of cool you
know and then yeah it's a whole thing's
information synthesis is so fast a
knowledge synthesis is so interesting
yes sometimes I'll find myself parsing
10 articles on the internet written by
different people on a topic like like
Amazon's hq2
we just did a video on that so I so I
would I would go synthesize 10 articles
and I was something that wasn't
relatable for the public and
multivariate so not his new one not just
binary good or bad and that go and I do
a video on it on our channel yeah so I
think there's a whole growing field of
knowledge synthesis that is very
fascinating yes like you then and that's
kind of cool and important and I feel
like it's almost you having to go to
them they're like you know we can do
this stuff you can help you and they're
like oh I think it would be cool yeah
yeah amazing you kind of have to be a
little like Polymathic and empathic
those are two words that I've been using
a lot over the last couple of years you
want to know a lot about a lot of
different things and you got a have a
deep sense to connection of emotional
intelligence and knowing how to properly
engage people on oh yeah human heart
level but also on on disseminating the
ideas and relatable ways yes and I have
seen examples of people not knowing how
to engage the public and turn them off I
have invited people to certain talks
where they would feel really and
welcomed because of some scientists said
something like you don't really get this
part you know so you have to also fix
those things that's so interesting that
you bring that up I think that that's
one that we forget about a lot it's the
idea that we will purposely try and
uplift our own ego yeah to pat ourselves
on the back to then the yes and versus
the note but conversation so if
someone's asking if they're saying
something wrong you know there's there's
a difference between being like now you
don't know what you don't know versus
saying that oh it's actually a little
bit different or somewhat different or
whatever you need to say to make that
person understand it and then you know
give them that love and that kindness
and rather than a disrespect and
rudeness and superiority that's a that's
a good there's a big thing in science
communication that what makes sense does
necessarily mean it's true it's not
about telling facts because that's not
changing people's minds it's about
meeting them on your different level
emotional level in terms of what their
worldview is that seems to work it's
harder than just saying well here's ABC
so don't you get it you know thing to
work you need to relate to people that's
cool so so so you you you you act I'm
fascinated with questions I just did a
talk on dart a powerful questions in San
Francisco and
over there and there was there was like
videos this is a super interesting way
of asking people questions gaining
perspective about their worldview then
meeting them with your knowledge that
you're trying to communicate them to a
level where you're now combining their
worldview or you're making their
worldview aware of what knowledge you're
teaching which is kind of what you're
saying is just spewing your own facts at
them and hoping that they integrate it
it's very big distinction between those
that's very interest I'm gonna have to
watch that video because that's a big
thing in science communication no I'll
find it anyway but it's about listening
right and we say it a lot in that
journal Club and people like ok we know
we know but what does that mean and how
he to do that well that's a certain
skill ya know I'm gonna have to watch
the video yeah I'll send it to you after
this and this is also I'm happy we
talked about science communication for
so long because I the you and you and I
just went and played some really
interesting tennis about about gumbo I'm
packing it that was a good set it was a
really strong segment I haven't done a
strong segment on science communication
wow that was a really strong winner yeah
that was good I want to ask you about
the what you're gonna be teaching in
January at Loyola Marymount in Los
Angeles yeah actually it's a very
interesting course it's in the political
science department which I'm not a
political scientist but it's preparing
students for a completely different
preparing them for the job market the
world out there how do you even talk to
people how do you not just how do you
write your resume and cover letter but
how do you go out there how do you make
yourself likeable a person who people
want to work with and just preparing
them basically giving them an internship
they're all doing an internship
reflecting on it and just really trying
to prepare them outside of school one of
the things I mean I did all these
degrees right and every time I left I
felt like I was never prepared to leave
and find what to do with all this
knowledge I just gained in the real
world so that's kind of one of the
points of the course it's like an
internship course I also guest lecture
I'll keep a guest lecturer in the
psychology department
it's the evolutionary psychology class I
tend to do the food stuff and I think
students really love it
seeing how we have evolved to have
certain food preferences but it's okay
that we love sugar and fat and would
hate bitter things thus we don't like
vegetables as much it's like a little
bit stuff so whoa so that's that's my
fun 150 so that's food it's like psych
psychology of food and food science
pretty much it's psychology of human
food preference preference but it goes
into all sorts of things like the fact
that like addictive to eat sugar versus
like it's really rewarding yes I wrote
an article about food addiction there's
a lot of science skeptics and proponents
and they don't know how to meet
something that it's just worse today
it's stupid
others are totally into it so I don't
have an answer if it's a thing food
addiction is real musics is real I would
say so but I don't have the data but it
makes sense to me but it's it's so-so
okay it's like these things yeah I've
been very rare for very rewarding and
you would never die civilization just
got to like the ability to be addicted
to food easily yeah funny thing is that
we seem to be adapting to these things
as well
I mean Road adapted to milk and grains
in many societies have developed certain
things to make them festival but it's
amazing like 7,000 years that's it yeah
so there are some talks about like this
kind of sucks not the best diet but
we're actually gonna be able to adapt to
it to not be all sick and super
overweight we'll see I don't know but in
okay so there's the psychology food
preference which is so cool I'm cool I
really like to see some recorded
sessions good okay good good I want to
see these and then also on the on the on
the on the like kind of like how to
present yourself into the with the
poli-sci side thinks I'm interested what
are some of the principles that you
recommend people to be likeable because
for I guess for me one that comes to
mind is when you first meet someone you
can kind of tell their vibe there or
really quick
and the more like loving and caring and
gentle and present you are with that
that that vibe between people the more
you'll get further in life in my opinion
and and also I think I think there's
another aspect to it which is even if
that person is not on that vibe they
will come down from there like let's say
they're an arrogance or their anger or
their frustration or whatever they're
feeling whatever it is probably
insecurity in one way or another you
know so you know this is all like
spoiler alerts because I haven't taught
the class yet and we were still I'm
co-teaching it with a brand Gilbert
she's amazing and she's totally class
before so we're gonna be thinking about
what we want to add to it but it's even
things like that you know I was talking
to the student the other day telling
them about the importance of you know
everyone you talk to just pay attention
to them you know listen to them it's all
things like that makes sense it was like
really you know it's just this kind of
attention to every person you talk to
them like yeah just like their one and
only and right in front of you because
that's what you're doing at the moment
you know and at some point when you're
looking for a job for a lot of faculty
positions you know when they closed
doors and discuss who they like they're
like did you write a paper with them but
you want to like be in the same room
with them at some point like we're great
and we have all the skills that's all
there but do you want to work with this
person because that's really important
or exactly so it's making sure you are
that kind of person that's flexible that
can work with anyone that's affects
others well and like you say he's even
able to bring down other people from
whatever they're dealing with by being
relaxed listening it's things that make
sense to all of us but I think they need
to be told to people yeah Wow yes it's
like the more the more grounded you are
in being calm and being kind and loving
the more you can help others ground
their even if they're not feeling it
also it was cool how you how you are you
said that like the simple one of even
giving someone the full perception the
full attention yeah while they're
speaking to you is so so so important
and it just it does it does feel like
the
these have slowly moved us in a strange
direction away from being able to give
and I and I went out and there's a
difference I think when I sit down with
someone and I say you know is it okay
with you if I take notes on what we're
talking about you know some of this is
that's very important or or you know
here I have notes about you talking
points that I want to address so it's
there and so so so I think there's
making a like a very transparent
distinction of focus but these these in
so many ways have taken us away from
giving a hundred percent attention yeah
yeah and there's I'm gonna be teaching
that there's amazing psychologists at
LMU and she looks into first impressions
basically and it's all this stuff this
should make sense already but it is
things like don't look down on your
phone unless you make a disclaimer and
the person knows why there's just
assuming that you're not paying
attention you know it's Royce icon check
this that shake your hand don't look at
your phone there's science behind it -
yeah yeah if you give that if you give
like a solid hug to someone you know if
you give a really loving like hug to
someone you can you can ease people you
can ground people you know if they don't
want a hug and you give a handshake you
know give them look em in the eyes and
give them a fairly firm handshake and
Express how interested you are in
chatting with them that's why you're
there you know it's you know it's not
fake and I manipulate in any way you're
actually paying attention so it's good
just being aware of it whoa I want to
pull your mind I like God I just like
the class idea so yeah well I want to
come down as a as a guest like I want to
put together like a guest like a guest
lecturer I'd love to come and do like a
you guys can
I'll send I'll send you an idea and then
if you want and if you guys like it then
I come down and I'm sure you have a lot
of interesting topics to discuss so yeah
that'd be a really cool thank you I
would be so honored to come and do that
and there and I just this has been so
fascinating and multivariate and
you know it's really interesting how
many people here are just hyper
multidisciplinary like you and even you
know Jason and Elise that we've had on
the show earlier today also been just so
so multidisciplinary yeah
that seems to be a very central trait of
anthropologists yeah and it's becoming
more and more popular and in some ways
it makes it a bit harder it makes it
harder in the job market because then
you don't have a particular field you're
really rooted in but it is the right
move you know one of the questions today
was like well you guys will come here
and your talk and then nothing happens
it's amazing how much we need to catch
up with all the knowledge production
that's happening we need this event
sometimes just be like what does
everyone else do and I have no idea I'm
not a robot you know yeah I can't get
all the information so that's where we
get in we listen to everything and it
effects our work and what we do next and
we know what someone else is not doing
so we could do it and you know fill the
gaps but the point is interdisciplinary
so important when I was doing my
research right I'm an anthropology but
I'm also pulling from nutrition and
psychology and I realized that this
builds don't always talk to each other
and you look at their literature as like
oh you're saying this all makes sense
but you're Alex you'll missing this you
should be also considering that from a
different field so you have yeah all
these things are complex they need
different lenses since the right move
and it's happening yeah
this has been so much fun and I think
you know I've learned a lot thank you
thank you for inviting me I'm glad we
ran into each other just like that yeah
exactly and I think there's reasons I'd
like to live in a world of magic and
possibility and joy and and there is a
reason for meeting people in the
universe because it's fun to live that
way so yeah yeah yeah so thanks everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
this has been a super fun episode the
give us your thoughts in the comments
we'd love to hear from you
check out Maria's links in the bio
please go look at her work also go and
build the future go manifest your
destiny into the world this has been an
awesome conversation in partnership with
the American Anthropological Association
triple a much love everyone and we will
see you soon thank you thanks Wow all
right you are professional and if you
did make it easier for me